مدينه خيرسون في الجنوب الاوكراني تتعرض
مجددا للقصف تفجيرات عديده دوت في كافه
انحاء
المدينه كانت ابنتي تقف هنا كان هناك
انفجار ضخم مروع للغايه لم اسمع شيئا كهذا
من قبل بدات ابنتي بالصراخ ولم افهم ماذا
حدث تستهدف مدينه خيرسون بانتظام منذ خروج
القوات الروسيه منها قبل اكثر من عام
لكن في الايام الاخيره تكثفت الهجمات خاصه
تلك التي استهدفت البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
هجمات دفعت بسكان المدينه الى الاقامه في
الملاجئ هذه هي الحصص اليوميه وهي مخصصه ل
150 شخصا لمده ثلاثه ايام على الاقل لدينا
هنا السلع المعلبه والحبوب والكافيار
والشاي والسكر
والمياه فضلا عن الجنوب الاوكراني ومنذ
فشل محاولتها الاوليه للتقدم نحو كيف تركز
القوات الروسيه على الشرق ايضا لاسيما في
بلده اف ديفك